[Musique]
on doit avoir une formation
obligatoirement musicale pour pouvoir
transformer effectivement ce morceau de
bois à ce qu'il en devient un instrument
de musique quoi c'est cette
transformation qui est très intéressante
à faire que quatre morceaux de bois
collés les uns aux autres d'ailleurs
trente deux morceaux de bois collés les
uns aux autres de vienne un violon - le
viol se compose de quatre parties la
table les éclisses le fond le manche
avec la volute et le cheviller pour
accorder et après l'accessoire qui se
met sur le manche la touche
je vais replacer son âme à la une bonne
place je regrette à l'intérieur et je
vais essayé de m'appliquer voilà
pourquoi c'est la table flamme entre la
tabelle fonds pour qu'elle puisse au
maximum faire passer les vibrations de
la table au fond pour que le fonds et la
table en même temps vibre en
accouplements pour faire venir
effectivement le son jusqu'à nos
oreilles quoi donc après on cherche le
meilleur emplacement c'est à dire le
noeud harmonique en fonction du diapason
de la longueur de corde et un endroit
précis où il ya plus de vibrations et
convient donc cherché récupérer avec
l'âme
[Musique]
je suis allé c'est vraiment la pièce
principale sur lequel parie qu'elle va
passer toute la vibration toute la
qualité du timbre et la puissance de
l'instrument donc c'est vrai que donc
les quatre cordes vont venir s'appuyer
est une résultante des forces va faire
qu'il ya le vibrations va être transmise
à la table par les deux côtés et au fond
par l'âme qui sera de soul a cédé
presque comme des bigoudis qu'on peu
disposées tout autour pour recoller bien
du bord qui nous permette de presser
alors on utilise de là on essaie
d'utiliser encore de la colle à
l'ancienne c'est-à-dire d'alcool à chaud
de la colle de zurich la colle dos ou de
nerf de boeuf qu'est la propriété de
pouvoir effectivement après ce re
décoller facilement quand justement il
ya un petit problème du niveau maîtrise
[Musique]
parfait très bien tout est en place on
va pouvoir tendre encore les cordes et
l'accord sera parfait le jeu est bon je
fais donc mes études en italie à cameron
à l'institut international de lutherie
antonio stradivarius où j'ai été diplômé
en 80 et par la suite j'ai donc fait
trois années de stage c'est différent
luthier en france pour parfaire mes
connaissances dans la réparation dans la
restauration et dans le dans le commerce
c'est le médecin de l'âme du but très
important parce que sans le luthier on a
beau être musicien tout ce qu'on veut
c'est un ennemi qui fait que ça sonne
[Musique]